je vous en parlais déjà en titre à blois
l'un des deux passagers de la voiture
accidentée mardi soir est décédé cet
après midi le jeune mineur n'a pas
survécu à ses blessures
le conducteur du véhicule qui a pris la
fuite est lui toujours activement
recherché est sur place on craint de
nouveaux débordements
et on s'interroge encore sur les raisons
de cette brutale poussée de violence
florent clavel et paul boyer dans les
quartiers nord de blois cet après-midi
ce qui frappe c'est le calme et
l'absence de tout policier
seuls quelques stigmates témoignent
encore de l'éruption de violence qui a
secoué la nuit de mardi à mercredi
les effets de l'important dispositif de
police déployé cette nuit mais aussi de
la médiation menée par le centre social
dès le lendemain des affrontements une
cinquantaine de jeunes s'y sont
retrouvés sous le choc après avoir
appris qu'un des accidentés étaient à ce
moment-là on état de mort cérébrale
certains connaissaient le jeune bien
évidemment il ya des émotions
il faut pouvoir entendre les jeunes sur
des éléments un ami qui à un moment
donné habite le quartier c'est
douloureux et c'est logique qu'on puisse
entendre cette jeunesse la perte d'un
adolescent du quartier l'embrasement qui
s'en est suivie cette irruption soudaine
de la violence a sidéré habitants et
policiers pour ce syndicaliste pas
d'angélisme
de violents heurts avaient déjà éclaté
en 2014 est selon lui une délinquance
quotidienne sévit dans ces quartiers
nord vols agressions deal mais rien ne
laissait présager une telle déflagration
le confinement le couvre-feu c'est quand
même un petit peu plus tendus les gens
sont il ya un mal être qui s'est
installée maintenant
non il n'y a pas de
de réponse exacte à cet embrasement
c'est un fait une divulgation rapide et
fausses d'informations sur les réseaux
sociaux qui ont fait que bas il ya eu un
embrasement les quartiers nord de blois
non pas ce profil caractéristique des
quartiers abandonnés par les pouvoirs
publics
peu de tours d'immeubles et des
logements de 5 étages maximum des
services des commerces et des
associations 350 millions d'euros
investi ces dernières années dans un
vaste plan de rénovation
pour l'adjoint à la jeunesse ce travail
de fond doit continuer il ya trop de
gens qui aujourd'hui se sentent
ghettoïser qui se sentent rejetés et je
crois effectivement que sur les
quartiers populaires tout l'engagement
qui est celui du service public et celui
des communes qui agissent dans matière
d'éducation en matière de prévention en
matière de culture de sport et bien ça
contribue à a donné un horizon assez à
ces populations
ce soir la préfecture du loir-et-cher
annonce la prolongation du dispositif de
sécurité dans les quartiers nord
et ce pour plusieurs jours